visual politic Community we have some
very bad news to tell you jihadism is
making a
comeback or at least that is what many
experts in both Europe and the United
States are already warning the vast
majority of analysts claim that the
phenomenon is experiencing a new Boom
the reason I'm sure you can already
guess 3 2 1 exactly we are talking about
the redh hot situation in which Israel
and Palestine or rather Hamas find
themselves but hadn't jihadist terrorism
disappeared no nothing could be further
from the truth if you are loyal
followers of visual politic you'll
remember that in places like Pakistan
Afghanistan and usbekistan attacks are
the order of the day and let's not
forget Africa the Sahel is infested with
jihadist terrorists Mali bin fazo Niger
in fact boo Haram one of the most
well-known Global jihadist terrorist
groups is based in Nigeria even in China
they have some problems with this issue
so where exactly do we say it is making
a comeback well particularly in Europe
in fact since the Hamas attack on Israel
and Israel's counter offensive we have
come across news items like these and
believe me it's no trivial matter France
raises attack alert after islamist kills
teacher in northern France Alert in
Italy reinforced surveillance in places
related to the Jewish Community Sweden
raises Terror alert level after Karan
burnings Denmark and Sweden have
tightened border controls as they fear
High threat attacks in Europe a little
over 10 years ago we had already
experienced what it was like to suffer a
jihadist attack every few years in the
end the phenomenon lost more and more
strength until the pandemic flattened it
nevertheless this time it may be
different analysts are already warning
of the new forms that jihadist terrorism
has taken in recent years forms that are
even more Elusive and more successful
than in the past and precisely because
of this we on visual politic have posed
a few questions how did Europe manage to
combat the wave of Jihan jism that
devastated it a few years back are we
really facing a new wave of jihadist
terrorism on the old continent why might
new forms of jihadism pose a greater
risk to Europe than previous ones today
we're going to answer all these
questions but in order to do so we have
to first look back in time let's get
started Europe in the face of
Terror did you know that in Europe
jihadist terrorism caught almost
everyone by surprise the old continent
was accustomed to another type of
terrorism one of a more nationalistic
and political nature such as that of ETA
in Spain or the IRA in the United
Kingdom however the truth is that the
European surprise was by no means
Justified some jihadist Fighters had
already begun to penetrate the old
continent in the 1980s and it did not
take long for them to start extending
the networks of larger groups such as
the Algerian islamist group or Al-Qaeda
itself this is how Europe began to
become an important jihadist
[Music]
Nest initially those networks LED mainly
by alqaeda were organized in a
hierarchical manner but following the
September 11th attacks in New York oama
Bin Laden decided to completely changed
that structure faced with the US
counterterrorism strategy aimed at
eliminating the leaders of the
organization and Global jihadism the
networks were decentralized but why
quite simply if Bin Laden and the rest
of the Ring leaders were taken out
Global jihadism could continue to
function without any problem what's more
it would be much more difficult to track
and combat as a result Europe
experienced a significant increase in
anti-terrorist operations that
dismantled some cells for example in
January 2003 two small jihadist cells
were dismantled in Italy and in Spain
the same year the famous operation lgo
took place in several locations in
Catalonia leading to the dismantling of
a medium-sized Algerian cell even so as
the decentralization strategy was
implemented everything became much more
complicated nothing prepared Europe for
what was to come on 11th of March 2004 a
jihadist cell attacked in Spain's
capital Madrid with 10 bombs planted in
different sections of public transport
the attack killed 193 people and injured
more than 2,000 it was the second
largest terrorist attack in the history
of the
continent as you can imagine this was a
turning point in how Europe perceived
jihadist terrorism concern about this
issue reached historic levels levels
that continue to grow after the London
subway bombing the following year in
2005 which killed another 50 people and
injured some 700 since then Europe has
been on a very high level of alert the
old continent suffered some minor
attacks and thwarted some major ones
such as the one that 14 jihadists linked
to alqaeda had planned in the Barcelona
Subway in January 2008 however despite
this in 2014 we would encounter news
that would take jihadist activity in
Europe to unparalleled levels Isis
Rebels declare Islamic State in Iraq and
Syria indeed Isis declared the Islamic
State and Global jihadism reached its
peak jihadist terrorism spread across
the globe and in Europe it hit
particularly hard and so began the first
jihadist wave that Europe has
experienced as
[Music]
such so visual politic viewers attacks
in European Union countries soared and
with them the fatalities 347 between
2015 and 2017 alone 86 of them just in
the brutal 2016 nce attack and it's not
just about the victims little by little
these attacks fed a general sense of
fear nevertheless between the
progressive weakening of Isis from 2017
and both joint and individual efforts by
European countries the jihadist threat
in Europe began to fall sharply to give
you an idea in 2022 only six attacks
took place but now the Hamas attack on
Israel and the Israeli response
particularly in Gaza has brought
tensions in the global Muslim Community
to a peak former Hamas leader khed mesal
went so far as to start in an ad that
many analysts interpreted as a call for
Global Jihad take note to all Scholars
who teach Jihad for the sake of God and
who preach the fighters and martyrs to
all who teach and learn this is a moment
of application of theories so that words
are not just words as a result both the
governments of Europe and the United
States have warned of a possible new
rise in jihadist terrorism but is this
really a call for Global Jihad wasn't it
supposed to be organizations like
alqaeda or Isis that were doing this
sort of thing well let's take a
look Global Jihad
resurfacing on 7th of October 2023 Hamas
perpetrated one of the bloodiest
terrorist attacks in Israel's history
more than 1,400 killed including
children women and the elderly the
images shocked the whole world many
compared it to the harshest era of Isis
including Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu Hamas bound burned
and executed children they are savages
Hamas is Isis and just as the forces of
civilization United to defeat Isis the
forces of civilization must support
Israel in defeating Hamas since then the
Israeli counter offensive has been
definitive it has entered Gaza and
bombed hundreds and hundreds hundreds
thousands of targets the global Muslim
Community has described this military
response as genocide and now the vast
majority of analysts fear that this is
the perfect excuse for a mass call to
Jihad the former Hamas leader has
already done so but do Michelle's words
have any relevance well probably yes but
enough to qualify it as a call for
international Jihad well most likely not
for one simple reason Alaya and Isis the
ultimate representatives of global
jihadism love Hamas as much as a Muslim
Muslim loves bacon in other words not at
all yes it is true Hamas alqaeda and
Isis are aligned on certain points their
hatred of Israel their perception of the
Hebrew country as a puppet of the West
and the promotion of violence against
the Jewish Community are some of them
but the reality is that the relationship
between these groups is pretty
[Music]
lousy since Hamas participated in the
Palestinian legislative council
elections in 2006 both alqaeda and Isis
have harshly criticized the Palestinian
organization the two leading exponents
of global jihadism condemned the
participation of Hamas in a democratic
process that both described as impure
once more hamas's slowness and
gradualism in imposing sharayah law in
Gaza has been another major source of
criticism from the other two terrorist
groups on top of that hamas's reproach
with Iran and Hezbollah has not been
particularly helpful in rebuilding its
ties either in fact Isis is particularly
harsh on Hamas which it criticizes for
not having as its clear objective the
establishment of a global Islamic State
but rather prioritizing The Liberation
of Palestine meanwhile alqaeda has
differentiated between the political arm
of Hamas which it strongly condemns and
its militarized arm the kasan brigades
which it does
[Music]
support with such an eroded relationship
no matter how much Hamas may call for a
global Jihad if its two main proponents
do not support them it is unlikely to
take place so the question is have both
alqaeda and Isis called for a global
Jihad well not completely but they have
come pretty
close you see following the Hamas attack
alqaeda applauded the action and took
the opportunity to call for attacks on
American Targets in the Middle East
especially in the major cities of the
countries that signed the Abraham
Accords Isis for its part never
congratulated Hamas and continued to
criticize them for their ties with Iran
it did however take the opportunity to
publish a list of Jewish targets to be
pursued anywhere in the world so whether
this is a call for Global Jihad or not
it is a call for targeted violence and
you know what it has already had and is
having
repercussions Egypt police officer
shoots Dead Two Israeli tourists and
Egyptian gu an employee at the Israeli
Embassy in China has been stabbed a
foreign suspect is detained these are
just three examples unfortunately
reports of anti-Semitic acts and
terrorist attacks seem be on the rise
and unsurprisingly they have also
reached Europe yet the problem in the
old continent may be even greater than
in the rest of the West why is that well
pay close
attention slippery
jihadism since the intense reactivation
of the Israeli Palestinian conflict
attacks by islamist radicals have once
once again taken up weekly space in the
international news the cases of Egypt
and China were among the first but
Europe regrettably has not been left
behind teacher killed and two injured in
stabbing at school in northern France
Russel shooting Europe shaken after two
swedes shot dead Germany arrests
islamist planning anti-israel terror
attack a man previously sentenced for
being a member of the so-called Islamic
state has been arrested according to
prosecutors he allegedly planned to
carry out an islamist Mot ated attack on
a pro-israel demonstration all of them
claimed to be acting on behalf of Isis
and one of them already had strong ties
to the international terrorist group
however these cases reveal something
much more important the new phase of
jihadist terrorism that has been
dominating Europe since the rise of Isis
we are talking about the figure of the
Lone
[Music]
Wolf the Lone Wolf which is an
individual who has been radicalized
autonomously and has had limited or no
contact with terrorist Serv CS has been
primarily responsible for terrorist
attacks in Europe for example between
2014 and 2017 the years of the jihadist
surge on the continent 85% of all
attacks were perpetrated by lone Wolves
at this time it is these terrorists that
are the greatest threat to Europe for
two reasons firstly because their
contact with terrorist cells is
sometimes Neil and therefore makes their
detection much more difficult and
secondly because they can attack with
everyday tools that do not arouse
suspicion such as knives without a doubt
they are a real headache for Western
National Security agencies these new
actors potentially more dangerous than
the terrorist cells that attacked Europe
at the beginning of the century are no
joke to give you an idea right now Spain
alone is tracking at least 300 potential
lone wolves crazy for this reason
European intelligence and security
agencies have been trying for some time
now to combat this phenomenon in one of
the areas that has generated the most
lone wolves social media and virtual
spaces you see while the Isis caliphate
faded away almost completely physically
its virtual presence has never waned in
fact during the quarantines in the first
wave of covid-19 its presence grew even
stronger and with it online recruitment
this is of particular concern as often
lone wolves learn how to assemble
explosive devices from various
recruiters and virtual trainers this was
for instance the case of the Manchester
buom in 2017 on the other hand the
online propaganda of jihadism although
simple has proven tremendously effective
by exploiting the identity confusion of
many second generation immigrants in
European countries and installing a
sense of victimhood against the supposed
aggression of the West and its societies
the recruiters of global jihadism have
been gaining more and more followers and
that means potential
[Music]
terrorists nevertheless many analysts
point to another place as a potential
nest of jihadists prisons in fact Medi
nush who was responsible for the 2014
bombing of a Jewish Museum in Belgium
was radicalized during his 5-year prison
sentence for robbery you see the fact is
that in European prisons today we find
hundreds if not thousands of former Isis
fighters who left the old continent to
fight in Iraq and Syria let's not forget
that more than 6,000 European citizens
went there well analysts and national
security agencies fear they are
radicalizing other inmates in prisons
making prisons potential jihadist
universities and as if that were not
enough there are also warnings of the
release of former European Isis
Fighters many have already served their
sentences and at their time of release
it is not known exactly what level of
radicalization they are still at so you
see visual politic Community Europe
seems to be about to embark on a new
wave of jihadist terrorism the risk is
definitely on the table the the global
Muslim Community is on edge and the
radical message being spread by Al-Qaeda
and Isis has already permeated a
minority but absolutely problematic part
of this community Europe prevailed
during the first wave of jihadist
terrorism less than a decade ago but
today lone wolves could put it in check
their greater versatility makes the
potential new jihadist wave in Europe
more difficult to stem forcing
intelligence and homeland security
agencies to reconfigure their
counterterrorism strategies but at this
point the questions are now for you do
you think that a new wave of jihadists
will eventually reach Europe how do you
think it could deal with the challenge
of the lone wolves do you see a possible
New Wave reaching the United States you
can leave me your answers in the
comments and as always don't forget that
here on visual politic we release new
videos every week so subscribe to this
channel hit the little bell so you don't
miss any of our updates if you like this
video like it and see you in the next
one all the best see you
[Music]
soon